Von mir aus können wir anfangen.
Bitte schön.
Schönen Abend.
Mein Name ist Cevik und ich bin heute Ihre zuständige Ärzte auf dieser Station
und möchte mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, Hauptsache, jemand hilft mir.
Ja, natürlich. Wir sind für Sie da.
Aber bevor Sie mir Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden nennen, bräuchte ich ein paar persönliche Daten.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Nicole Magher.
Magher, könnten Sie bitte mit mir Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen bestabieren?
Ja, Nicole, N-I-C-O-L-E.
O-L-E.
Und Magher, M-A-G-E-R.
Okay.
Nein, Frau. Nicole ist ein Frau-Namen.
Nicole, ja. Okay.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Magher?
Ich bin 58 Jahre.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 5. Juli, 66.
66, okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,63.
Okay. Wie viel wiegen Sie zuzeit?
Ja, ich wiege noch 71 kg zurzeit.
Okay, vielen Dank für die Informationen, Frau Magher.
Welche Beschwerden haben Sie? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, also ich habe so Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, das hat schon vor langer Zeit angefangen.
Seit drei Wochen habe ich das immer mal nach dem Essen.
Aber jetzt hat sich das mit einmal wirklich dramatisch verschlechtert.
Und zwar, also jetzt sind die Schmerzen wirklich fast unerträglich.
Schmerzen im Oberbauch.
Und ja, also mir ist unglaublich schlecht.
Ich musste mich, also ich musste mich noch nicht übergeben.
Aber ich habe eigentlich immer das Gefühl, so, oh, jeden Moment.
Und ja, dann habe ich eben etwas Merkwürdiges beobachtet,
dass bei meinem Stuhlgang, dass da Blut dabei war.
Und dann hatte ich heute, gestern Abend, spät und heute Mittag,
hatte ich einmal so ganz schwarzen Stuhlgang.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, oh, Mensch, das ist, das ist aber,
jetzt glaube ich, wirklich nicht mehr so gut.
Jetzt muss ich doch mal dringend zu Ihnen gehen.
Und wissen Sie, mein Hausarzt ist im Urlaub.
Und deswegen bin ich sofort hier zu Ihnen gekommen.
Also mein Mann hat mich, hat mich gebracht.
Der ist zum Glück gerade zu Hause, weil er wusste,
dass es mir nicht so gut geht.
Und der hat mich gebracht.
Und ich fühle mich so schlapp und so schlecht.
Ja, also mir geht es gar nicht gut.
Sie haben Oberbauchschmerzen, können Sie genau sagen,
oder zeigen, wo diese Schmerzen in der Mitte,
rechte Seite oder linke Seite?
Ja, in der Mitte, also oberhalb vom Bauchnabel würde ich sagen.
Und in diesen 3 Ektaren, wo die Rippen auffahren,
und es tut so weh.
Okay, die Schmerzen, die schmerzen die Schmerzen, die schmerzen, die schmerzen, die schmerzen.
Die schmerzen, die schmerzen, die schmerzen, die schmerzen.
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Das drückt nur da, heftig, in den Bauch.
Drückende Schmerzen können Sie beschreiben.
Ja, ganz heftiger Druck.
Wie stark Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkalafon 0 bis 10, wobei 0 keine Schmerzen 10, sehr heftige Schmerzen entspricht.
Also, warum nicht? Ich würde sagen, das ist bei 8 von 10.
8?
Ja.
Frau Magier, können Sie Ihre Schmerzen bis zum Ende dieses Gespräch aushalten oder möchten Sie ein Schmerz?
Das wird ja nicht so lange dauern, aber dann wäre ich schon dankbar, wenn Sie eben so etwas unternehmen können.
Ja, okay.
Jetzt ich unterbreche dieses Gespräch und dann erst mal Vitalparametermessen.
Dann können wir weitermachen, okay?
Okay.
Aber ich würde Ihnen empfehlen, ein bisschen nüchter sein.
Deswegen schmerzmittel gebe ich Ihnen jetzt nicht.
Das dauert nicht so lange.
Ich bitte Sie um ein bisschen.
Ja, ja, weil ich habe Sie bis jetzt auch ausgehalten.
Ja.
Okay, okay, vielen Dank.
Und Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass diese Schmerzen nach dem Essen verstärkt, verstärken sich.
Ja.
Da fing das eigentlich an immer nach dem Essen.
Und jetzt habe ich, heute habe ich ja fast nichts gegessen, weil mir das alles so weh getan hat.
Ja, da habe ich mal versucht, ein bisschen Zwieback zu essen.
Und jetzt habe ich das Gefühl, jetzt kann ich auch nicht mehr.
Ich bin so schlapp.
Okay, ja, schnapp.
Und Sie haben schon erwähnt, ist Ihnen ein Öbel?
Ja, mir ist sehr schlecht.
Ich muss mich nicht erbrochen.
Nee, übergeben muss ich mich nicht.
Okay.
Und haben Sie etwas dagegen eingenommen?
Nein, ich habe mich gar nicht getraut, weil ich das so gar nicht kenne.
Ja, Sie haben gute Entscheidungen gemacht.
Haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden?
Hatten Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden?
Nein, also ich hatte mal vor sechs Jahren,
nie einen Steine, da habe ich auch so heftige Schmerzen gehabt,
aber eben an einer anderen Stelle.
Ja, also ich kann schon Schmerzen eigentlich aushalten,
aber diese Bauchschmerzen, so wie jetzt,
nee, das habe ich noch nicht so gar in dieser Form.
Okay, bestellen die Schmerzen immer dauerhaft oder kommen und gehen Sie wieder?
Nein, ich finde, ich ständig da.
Ständig, ja.
Sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich auch getreten?
Ja, würde ich sagen, das ist mit einmal, hat das angefangen, ja.
Ich meine, das war nicht von Anfang an so schlimm, sonst wäre ich natürlich eher gekommen.
Und weil das immer nach dem Essen kam, habe ich gesagt, okay,
muss man ein bisschen vorsichtiger essen und dann beruhigt sich das schon wieder oder so,
aber es ist eben jetzt, wie gesagt, immer schlimmer geworden.
Hey, seit drei Wochen haben Sie diese Schmerzen, aber nicht...
Ja, ja, und dann hat sich das immer so gesteigert, ja.
Okay, immer schlimmer geworden, ich verstehe.
Und diese sind Ihnen über, nur heutzutage auch drei Wochen, haben Sie überkalkt?
Nein, nee, das ist mir so schlecht, war wie jetzt,
das ist erst seit gestern eigentlich.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass zweimal Strunklerstuhl hat,
ist das Tierstuhl, kann man sagen.
Ja, das sah so ganz schwarz-äglich aus, ja.
Okay, gestern Abend und heute, zwei Mal.
Heute Mittag, ja.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie heute...
Das war nicht so viel, das waren keine großen Mengen, aber das sah ganz komisch aus, ja.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen eine Schwindel, Frau Maga, oder Schwarz vor den Augen?
Schwarz vor den Augen, nee, das ist nicht,
nee, schwindelig ist mir auch nicht.
Schwindel, nee.
Und haben Sie Lassehaut bemerkt?
Lassehaut?
Nein, eigentlich bin ich jetzt noch vom Sommer gut gebräunt, also ich würde sagen, ich bin nicht besonders blass,
aber kann ich mich auch täuschen.
Ja, okay.
Und Sie fühlen Sie sich immer abgeschlagen, Herr Schöpfer?
Ja, das ist richtig, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber, Frau Maga?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber richtig fieberig fühle ich mich eigentlich nicht.
Fieberig nicht, okay. Leiden Sie unter Schüttheifrost, Nachtschweiß?
Nee, also ich habe heute Nacht zwar schlecht geschlafen, aber geschwitzt habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Nicht, okay.
Haben Sie Angewicht in der letzten Zeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich zwei Kilo abgenommen in letzter Zeit, also in den letzten drei Wochen.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ja, zurzeit natürlich wirklich ganz schlecht, normalerweise kann ich eigentlich gut essen und schmeckt es mir auch,
aber wie gesagt, als das dann mit den Magenschmerzen anfing, habe ich dann auch so ein bisschen vorsichtig gegessen und so,
so leichte Kost und nicht so viel Gemüse wie sonst und Rohkost.
Und ja, dann habe ich halt das auch darauf geschoben, dass ich jetzt nicht so viel gegessen habe, dass ich Gewicht abgenommen habe.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Ernähren Sie sich immer, wie ernähren Sie sich immer Fettige essen oder ausgehauen?
Ja, ich esse schon auch gerne mal etwas Fettiges, aber ja eigentlich so wie alle Leute hier,
bisschen Fleisch, bisschen Gemüse, bisschen Brot, was man halt so ist.
Okay, das ist gut.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, nein, nein, beim Wasserlassen habe ich keine Probleme.
Sie sind routinmäßige Fragen, deswegen frage ich.
Und zweimal dunkler Stuhl haben Sie ansonst andere Schwierigkeiten beim Stuhlgang?
Nein, normalerweise funktioniert das alles gut.
Verstopfung oder Durchfall?
Nein, habe ich weder Verstopfung noch Durchfall.
Nein, so etwas habe ich nicht.
Okay, leiden Sie unter Husten oder Atemnot?
Nein, okay.
Nein, ich bin nicht erkältet oder so.
Ja, okay.
Leiden Sie unter Herzlasen?
Nein, nein, nein, ich habe nur diese Bauchschmerzen, also das Herz, das schlägt nicht besonders wild.
Nein.
Ja, manche Krankheiten stehen zusammenhang mit diesen Beschwerden, deswegen frage ich.
Okay.
Und jetzt komme ich zu Ihren Vorerkrankungen.
Leiden Sie unter, leiden Sie andauerhaften Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich meine, was hat jeder in meinem Alter nicht?
Ich habe ein bisschen hohe Blutdruck und ich habe ein bisschen hohe Blutfettwerte.
Dann nehme ich halt auch Tabletten.
Ich kann gar nicht sagen, also wegen dieser Blutfette kriege ich ein Statin.
Und dann habe ich irgendwas gegen Bluthochdruck, da fällt mir gar nicht ein, wie das jetzt heißt.
Haben Sie eine Liste dabei?
Bitte?
Haben Sie eine Liste, eine Medikamentliste dabei?
Nein, die habe ich zu Hause liegen lassen, weil das ja zu Holter, die Holter ging.
Aber da kann ich meinem Mann nachher sagen, dass er die noch mitbringt.
Ja, okay, nach Hause, die Sprit, machen wir so.
Und diese Statin kennen die Dosierung?
Bitte?
Für diese Statin.
Blut, Erkrankungen?
Ich kann Ihnen jetzt nicht sagen, wie das heißt.
Ich weiß nur, dass ich das immer abends einnehme.
Okay.
Und Medikament gegen Bluthochdruck auch?
Das nehme ich morgens.
Und andere Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Ja, also wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe, dann nehme ich Ibuprofen.
Und dann habe ich noch eine Cortisonsalve,
weil ich schon eigentlich, ja eigentlich seit Kinderzeiten
unter so einer Schuppenflechte leide.
Und wenn das mal wieder so hoch kommt und die Hautregion juckt
und schuppt, dann behandle ich das eben mit Cortisonsalve.
Cortisonsalve, okay.
Welche Dosierung nehmen Sie diese Ibuprofen ein?
Kennen Sie die Dosierung?
Oh, ich meine, da steht 800 drauf.
800, okay.
Aber jetzt habe ich das nicht genommen.
Und dazu nehmen Sie Magenschutz ein?
Magenschutz nehme ich nicht mehr.
Okay.
Und häufiger nehme ich häufig?
Ja, ich nehme das eigentlich nur, wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen habe
oder so, was weiß ich, zu viel gearbeitet, zu wenig geschlafen.
Ja, dann mache ich das mal.
Ich verstehe ansonst keine Medikamente.
Und auch Schuppenflechte, auch die andere Krankheit bei Ihnen?
Ja, sonst wüsste ich nicht, was noch ist.
Okay.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert, Frau Maga?
Ja, also wie gesagt, ich hatte ja mal Nierensteine.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob man das Operation nennen kann,
da habe ich halt so eine Haareleitestine bekommen.
Haareleite.
Schiene.
Okay.
Wann war das?
Das ist schon sechs Jahre her.
Okay.
Und seit her habe ich aber auch eigentlich keine Probleme mehr.
Und andere Operationen?
Ja, ich muss überlegen, als Kind,
ich meine, ich bin noch vollständig, es ist alles noch drin.
Ja, das freut mich.
Und Bluthochdruck, seit wann haben Sie?
Ja, das hat man so vor neun Jahren festgestellt.
Erhöckte Blutwerten seit wann?
Ja, das ist so in einem Zug, hat man das festgestellt,
mal in so einer Routine-Untersuchung,
oh ja, das, was ich ihre Blutstelle werde,
sind ja hoch und ihr Blutdruck ist ein bisschen hoch.
Ja, seit neun Jahren nehme ich jedenfalls die Medikamente.
Und Schuppen, vielleicht, seit...
Oh, das habe ich schon ewig.
Das habe ich schon, schon als Jugendliche, also über 40 Jahre.
So, gänzlich, okay.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Dann sind Ihnen dann irgendwelche Allergien
oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt, Frau Mager?
Das Einzige, wo ich aufpassen muss,
ist braunes Flaster.
Da reagiert die Haut halt mit so juckenden, trustelnden.
Okay.
Und sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, also gegen Corona bin ich geimpft
und diese üblichen Impfungen habe ich alle bekommen, ja.
Ja, das ist schön.
Und waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Nee.
Unser Urlaub waren wir an der Nordsee?
Nee, also im Ausland war ich gar nicht.
Okay, und sind Sie in Wechseljahr, Frau Mager?
Ja, also eigentlich bin ich da schon so ziemlich durch damit, ja.
Also ich habe jetzt schon seit zwei Jahren keine Blutung mehr.
Seit zwei Jahren, okay.
Besuchen Sie Ihre Frauenarzt regelnmäßig?
Ja, natürlich, da gehe ich immer hin, ja, zur Kontrolle.
Okay.
Einmal im Jahr.
Ja, das freut mich.
Und jetzt komme ich zu Ihren Lebensgewohnheiten.
Rauchen Sie, Frau Mager?
Ja, leider ja.
Konnte ich mir noch nicht abgewöhnen.
Also ja, das mache ich schon seit ich 30 bin.
Rauchig blöd.
Warum habe ich eigentlich angefangen?
Aber ich rauch nicht viel.
Ich rauch also kein Päckchen am Tag.
Also 5-10 Zigaretten vielleicht am Tag.
Zigaretten täglich und mit 30 Jahren.
Seit, ja, also seit ich 30 bin, genau.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol, also ich trinke ein, zwei Flaschen Bier am Abend,
aber sonst eigentlich kein Alkohol.
Jeden Tag trinken Sie?
So gut wie jeden Tag, ja, so zum Abendessen.
Guten Tag.
Auch Nikotin und Alkohol konsumt bei Ihnen ein bisschen viel.
Ich würde Ihnen unbedingt empfehlen,
damit aufzuhören oder Min-Distance reduzieren.
Nach unserem Geschmack.
Ja, jetzt in den letzten Tagen habe ich natürlich kein Bier getrunken.
Das kann ich nicht mit glauben, ja.
Zigaretten schmecken, um Augenblick auch nicht, ja.
Okay, wenn Sie wollen, können wir auch dabei unterstützen.
Und jetzt Sie gefragt, nehmen Sie bitte nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie einen Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen?
Ja.
Also nicht mal Kontakt mit jemandem, der Kontakt mit Drogen hat.
Nein, also überhaupt nicht.
Ja, das ist sehr gut.
Das ist eine Routinefrage, deswegen frage ich.
Und jetzt komme ich so Ihre Familien vor Geschichte.
Nehmen Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, mein Vater ist verstorben.
Er hat einen schweren Verkehrsunfall und ist dabei ums Leben gekommen.
Meine Mutter lebt aber noch.
Und die ist aber nicht gesund.
Die hat so eine Blutungsstörung in den Beinen.
Und hat im Augenblick gerade so eine offene Stelle,
die nicht gut verheilt und ist da ständig beim Arzt deswegen.
Offene Wunde hat sie in den Beinen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und haben Sie Geschwister, Frau Maga?
Nein, ich bin ein einziger Kind.
Ja, okay.
Und Sie haben am Anfang erwähnt, dass Sie von Ihrem Mann mitgebracht sind.
Ja, der hat mich in die Kinder gebracht, genau.
Okay, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben zwei Kinder, aber die sind aus seiner ersten Ehe.
Das sind meine Stiefkinder.
Okay, Stiefkinder.
Ich habe keine eigenen Kinder.
Okay, was machen Sie beruflich?
Früher, was hatten Sie beruflich gemacht?
Ich bin immer noch berufstätig.
Ich bin Buchhänderin.
Buchhänderin, okay.
Und haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Eigentlich nicht so sehr.
In der Vorweihnachtszeit ist es immer mal stressig,
oder wenn gerade Buchmesse war, aber eigentlich ist es nicht stressig.
Und ich liebe meinen Beruf.
Okay, und noch letzte Frage.
Wir haben drei Minuten zuvor.
Okay, ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen, Frau Maga.
Ich möchte Sie etwas hinzufügen.
Ja, ich will uns natürlich wissen, was da die Ursache ist,
warum das so weht und eben, was man dagegen machen kann.
Ja, und wie ich das verhindern kann, dass so etwas wiederkommt.
Es ist zufällig etwas genauer zu sagen,
aber nach jedem Angaben habe ich eine Vermöhtung auf
Magenblutung, Magen-Darm-System.
Oh, ist das schlimm?
Ja, wenn es nicht behandelt, könnte es schlimm sein.
Deswegen werde ich Sie schnellstmöglich körperlich untersuchen
und Blut entnehmen, dann mit gelbendes Verfahren durchführen.
Und werde ich mit meinem Oberarzt schliessen.
Das ist ein bildgebendes Verfahren da.
Was macht man da?
Das ist das, das meine ich Bauchultraschall.
Ah, okay, ja.
Das ist auch nicht real, ne?
Natürlich auch nicht real.
Und dann je nach Ergebnisse können wir entscheiden,
was wir machen.
Okay.
Ja, das klingt doch gut, ja.
Leider endet die Summe mit in sechs, zehn Minuten.
Müssen wir neu machen?
Nein, ich habe ein Abonnement-Problem.
Deswegen könnten wir als Erzars-Geschichte schnell laufen.
Okay.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen
und möchte Ihnen den Fall vorstellen.
Ja, natürlich gerne.
Es handelt sich Nicole Maghe.
Sie ist 58 Jahre alt und 1,63 m groß und 71 kg schwer.
Frau Maghe wurde wegen seit drei Wochen bestehender, drückender,
anhaltender und progrediente Obelbachschmerzen
im epigastischen, abdominärschmerzischen Bereich
ohne Ausstrahlung bei uns mitgebracht.
Und sie ordnet die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala 8 von 10.
Aus erdem leide die Patienten als Begleitzymptome unter nausea ohne emesis
und melena, 2-malige melena gestern ab und heute mittag.
Desweiteren erwähnt die Patienten, dass die Schmerzen nach dem Essen
verstärken.
Sie haben früher ähnliche Beschwerden, keine.
Und die Fragen, vertigo, blasehaut, tochi kardi,
wurden verneint, auch darüber hinaus,
dass die Schmerzen sich die Patienten abgeschlagen.
Und die vegetativ an der Sitzzeit 2 kg Gewichtabnahme
und Inappetenz.
In welchem Zeitraum?
Die Gewichtabnahme?
Ich habe das nicht gefragt, aber bei der Kölpelchen-Unterversuchung
war es in 3 Wochen.
Die Patient hat gesagt, 3 Wochen in 3 Wochen.
Ich habe nicht gemerkt, deswegen vergesse ich.
Und als Vorerkrankungen seien bei der Patientin Artereal-Hypertony
und Hyperlipidemis seit 9 Jahren und Hypstöriasis seit Jugendlich.
Seit dem Jugendalter.
Als Voroperationen nannte die Patienten Nephrolithiasis,
die sich Katheter mit Katheter behandelt wurden.
Ja, okay, sehr gut.
Die Medikamente ergab Stadt, einmal Abends
und ein Medikament gegen Artereal-Hypertony,
aber unbekannte Names und Dosierungen der Patienten.
Und diesbezüglich werde ich mit dem Hausarztkontakt aufnehmen.
Und noch Medikamente, Ibuprofen, 800 Milligramm gegen Stefalgi.
Auf ich ohne Protompompa hema und Cortisolzalbe gegen Psyriasis.
Beide Patienten seien grauenes Blaster allergiebekannt,
die sich mit Psyriasis und Puritis,
und der im Status sei vollständig und die Reise an Amnese ist unauffällig.
Die Patientin sei seit 2 Jahren in Wechsel, in Menopause.
Und sie besuche Frauenarzt regelmäßig und sei alles in Ordnung.
Die Patientin sei Braucherin mit 15 Zikaretentäglich
seit dem Alter 30.
Das beträgt schwer zu rechnen.
Ja, also rundgerechnet Augenblick,
20, der 18 Pecki ist ungefähr, würde ich sagen, ungefähr.
Ja, genau, ich habe es nicht ausreichend.
Und sie trinken ein bis zwei Fläche Flaschen via täglich
und der Druck der Konsum wurde verneint.
Der Familien an Amnese sei der Vater wegen Unfall,
wegen eines Unfall verstorben
und die Mutter leide wahrscheinlich perfere arteriale Verschlusskrankheit.
Und sie sei ein sehr Kind.
Frau Magen sei verheiratet, habe zwei Stiefkinder
und sei Buchhandlerin vom Beruf
und habe keinen Stress bei der Arbeit.
Nach diesen anamnestischen Angaben habe ich einen Verdacht
auf Obergasruin-Testinalblutung
und als Differenzialdiagnose kommen in Betracht
Ulcus ventriculi
und Magenkarcinum, Kolonkarcinum auch.
Und was machen Sie diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Ich habe es einmal körperlich untersucht,
inspektiere ich die Patienten-Blasen-Haut,
gucke ich und bei der Abdominalpall-Passion
epigastische Druckschmerzen achte ich darauf.
Und dann digital untersucht mache ich unbedingt.
Und dann double-Untersuchungen werde ich durchführen
und Blutbild um Hemoglobin-Werte.
Ja, genau, wichtig.
Und Entzündungsparameter werde ich beurteilen
und Blutgruppe und Gerinnungsparameter.
Okay, und auch die Wahrscheinlichkeit
für die Differenzialdiagnose,
Kolesterolparameter oder Amylase-Lipase
und andere Differenzialdiagnose auszuschließen.
Dann werde ich als Apparativdiagnose
erst einmal Abdominalzone-Gruppe durchführen.
Was wäre das nachfolgende,
wahrscheinlich erforderliche Verfahren,
ein bisschen invasiver?
Ja, genau.
Um mögliche Ursache oder
herauszukinden und gleichzeitig zu behandeln.
Genau.
Dr. Gündes, wie viele Minuten haben wir noch?
1 Minute, 10 Sekunden.
Ja, also um das mal kurz zu machen,
es war perfekt.
Sie waren richtig, richtig gut.
Sie haben eine sehr schöne Anamnese gemacht
und sie haben auch wirklich sehr vollständig zusammengefasst,
sehr systematisch.
Also sprachlich meine ich überhaupt keine Probleme.
Also ich habe mir eine Sache notiert,
sie wurde bei uns mitgebracht.
Also sie wurde, vorstellig würde ich vielleicht sagen,
aber ansonsten haben sie auch diesen berühmten ersten Satz
hervorragend gemeistert.
Sie haben sich also wirklich wacker geschlagen
und haben auch diesen Schnelldurchgang jetzt
sprachlich wirklich super absolviert.
Kann man nur sagen, das war wirklich gut.
Mit Zeitdruck, schnell alles durchbringt.
Und das war wirklich vollständig.
Das war wirklich vollständig.